welcome back to uncensored now in case
you've been in a Cupboard all day or
haven't gone on social media let me tell
you that the coffee chain cost of coffee
has caused a funeral following an advert
they sort of put on the side of a van
basically featuring a cartoon of what
appears to be a post-operative
transsexual man now critics who've been
very angry about this online all day say
it's glorifying and celebrating
irreversible surgical procedures for
young women a spokesperson for those
behind this mural from Costa said quote
at Costa Coffee we celebrate the
diversity of our customers team members
and partners we want everyone that
interacts with us to experience the
inclusive environment that we create to
encourage people to feel welcome free
and unashamedly proud to be themselves
the mural in its entirety showcases and
celebrates inclusivity now we're going
to be talking about this now is it
outrageous woke propaganda or just a
storm in a coffee cup who better to then
to give us our opinions on this than CEO
of the LGB Alliance Kate Barker and
celebrated lgbtqi plus campaigner Peter
tachel thank you both for making time to
talk about this and I'll just uh if you
don't mind giving you my view on it and
I sort of included it within the opening
sort of talk in the show regards nuclear
so you know we've taken off the ball
here we need some perspective on this
there's fewer other issues like this
drives me absolutely up the wall
um I understand there's important
sensitive debates and discussions to be
had about the trans movement and about
its place in society but I am slightly
exasperated by the attention that this
type of stunt gets and I might concern
is that corporates and companies and
exploiting the experience of trans
people saying that they're being
inclusive but at the same time knowing
that it's just going to generate so much
controversy and conversation around
their brand that they won't be forgotten
about sure some people may boycott cost
a coffee not get their coffee but some
people may well go in and that's
successful Marketing in and of itself my
fear about all these things is always is
that trans people haven't been included
or consult within this debate
um I'm obviously far on probably the
more left and wokey end of this than
some other people on this network as
well but I want to come to you and ask
for your opinion on this
um let's just start with you Kate I mean
well I mean to start reading I think
it's actually it's ghoulish and it's
grotesque and and it's really greedy of
Costa imagine thinking what's really
going to make our Tails ring I know the
the mutilation and the misery of girls
who hate their bodies and this isn't
about a trans issue this is about girls
who are opting for bilateral
mastectomies they're having healthy
breast tissue removed and it's not a
niche issue it's not a small issue
before I came on this afternoon I hopped
on to GoFundMe and I into the search bar
I put Top surgery and there are 8 649
girls
shaving up hoping planning for Top
surgery GoFundMe is only one platform
there are loads and loads of others so
what we're looking at really is tens and
thousands of girls in the UK
trying to save up money to get this done
now so it's not Niche I I don't think I
like your storm in a coffee cup but I I
don't I don't think it is and I think
it's about vulnerable girls I don't
think it's a transition I think that
adds that adds too much
um heat to the debate I think it's very
much more about
girls who are gender non-conforming and
I would say that a lot of those girls
are tomboys what used to be called
tomboys like like me when I was a kid I
didn't like I didn't like uh dresses and
pink and I wanted to play football
um and I if I was 12 now
and I saw all this and I saw the
glorification if I was being cheered on
to go ahead and to mutilate myself I
would have just leapt onto that
bandwagon with with
um with both feet I see the point you're
making uh mutilate to me is a strong
word when it's obviously we're talking
about people who are young doing this
and we don't know the person on the cost
of Anne could be 26 but the the core of
the debate is of course that young
people in the in this sort of industrial
complex of breast removal and
augmentation and everything else like
that are being exploited Peter but if
it's voluntary is it mutilation I mean
it's a strong terminology
well first let me say that I think that
the obsession with the Trans issue is
out of all proportion we have more than
seven million people in our Hospital
waiting lists some of them are dying
because they can't get surgery and we're
obsessing over a cartoon on a coffee van
that's absurd priorities but to answer
your point directly
in this country no one can have gender
reassignment surgery before the age of
17 as a minimum in England that's right
let me let me let me I didn't interrupt
you let me let me finish let me you
didn't drop
in England not before the age of 17
except if there are exceptional
circumstances but most people
will wait three to five years to get
their first appointment at a gender
identity clinic they'll have to have a
series of further appointments usually
between six months and one year apart
and then they have to wait another three
to five years to have the surgery so
it's very rare for anybody to have
surgery before the mid to late 20s and I
know people in their early 30s who are
still waiting having applied 13 years
ago okay so you're saying that the issue
isn't as uh grossly out of proportion or
it's not happy as frequently as some
might think and some people are
struggling at this Kate you had a point
yeah it's actually false that no
children are being operated on the NHS
has highlighted 51
not very many but 51 girls age 16 and 17
who've had mastectomies and I know you
think mutilation is is a bit extreme but
you know those that's healthy breast
tissue that those operations are really
really serious and there's a reason why
why people like Peter call it Top
surgery because I've heard you mention
it before because it's it's sanitizes it
sounds quite cute and neat and easy and
simple but it isn't it's a really
serious surgery ask any woman that's had
breast cancer what it's like to have
have a mastectomy and to do that to
yourself to health your healthy body
it's irreversible I think it's the only
Silver Lining is that people do have to
wait a long time is there an age at
which you would deem it accept or
somebody to make that decision
themselves our position is that for a
very small minority of people who've had
the proper support proper counseling had
time to think having a surgery a
cosmetic surgery which enables them to
resemble the opposite sex is a good
option for and we hope that would help
them to live a happy life I don't think
it's down to ages except we would say
never ever ever for children it's
absolutely wrong let's listen uh to some
testimony now in fact this is the story
of Chloe Cole she's a d transitioner
27th of July 2023 her 19th birthday
testified to congress with a final
warning that Medical Treatments to
change the gender of confused children
is quite horrific let's take a listen
we need to stop telling children that
puberty is an option puberty is a Rite
of Passage to adulthood not a disease to
be mitigated my childhood was ruined
along with thousands of deep
transitioners that I know through our
networks enough children have already
been victimized by this barbaric
pseudoscience please let me be your
final warning
oh Peter interesting points already
brought up by both of you this evening
and that separating this almost from the
trans discussion because you've got
other things going on here you've got
people as Kate said who prefer to look
like a tomboy you've also got the issue
of age and consent going on here when
you hear Chloe's testimony uh how do you
think that plays into the way the public
are perceiving all this well I'm very
sorry for Chloe that she went through a
bad experience
but she did not go to that experience uh
as far as I'm aware under pressure or in
a short space of time this resulted in
many years of counseling and seeing
Specialists and then she decided to go
ahead with it now I'm sorry that she
regrets it I'm very sorry for her but
there are only less than one percent of
trans people who have gender
reassignment surgery reject a reject or
have regrets about it you know 99 or
almost 99 say it has dramatically
improved the quality of their lives
they're happier more fulfilled
individuals and their families and
friends support that so for most people
Chloe's experience is not typical
gender reassignment surgery is life
enhancing and it does mean a better
quality of life for the people go
through it so I would say Live and Let
Live oh okay so statistically Peter
saying exception to the rule I mean
that's that simply false we don't have
any data uh for the for the huge influx
of young people who've been having those
kind of surgeries in the past few years
we have no long-term data and that
that's just plucked out of the air that
99 you know that's that's a very
suspicious three major three major
surveys so so what we do have we'd have
no evidence that children particularly
girls are any happier after their
surgery we have a lot of evidence for
example that most children who allowed
to go through adolescence un-medicalized
80 to 90 percent grow out of their
feelings of dysphoria
so we would always argue that waiting is
best we see what's happened with this
poor girl Chloe I think that in years to
come we're not going to remember the
names of these girls because there's
going to be a flood of them
and do you think that they've been
caught up in a Zeitgeist Peter I mean
returning back to the original source of
this conversation Costa Coffee can you
believe it but the way that the
narrative has been pursued by corporates
by companies but also by Society do you
think people are getting caught up in it
teenagers young people influenced by
social media
there may be a tiny element of that but
it's not typical and not the norm the
vast majority of people and I I know
dozens and dozens of trans women I wish
Kate would stop calling them girls
they're not girls they're mature women
often in their 20s 30s and 40s Chloe is
15. yes and I just I just explained that
I had sympathy with her but she's in the
United States she's not here here in
this country people have to wait years
typically for General reassignment
surgery from the very first application
to have a gender identity Clinic
appointment it will take 10 or more
years for them to have any surgery
during which time they are counseled and
given support so they've got opportunity
to reconsider and to assess whether
they're making the right decision so the
idea this is rushed or forced on people
is simply false and it's really painful
for those many trans people have to wait
all these years to get the surgery that
will affirm who they truly are and make
them happy I just say that is eight and
a half thousand young people mostly
girls who are crowdfunding for their
surgery aren't going through the NHS I
was I was busy on Google today and I had
a look at clinics in London where you
can go and get gender reassignment
surgery and the prices for it and they
are absolutely booming so the NHS is one
thing and there is a long wait time but
people are funding for surgery
themselves and they're going to clinics
which are taking advantage of people who
dislike their own bodies it's an
absolute Scandal
we agree we agree and no one should be
rushed into this yeah but no one should
make a swift decision yeah it has to be
thought through very carefully people
have to be counseled they have to be
questioned and they have to be given
other options and then if they decide
that's what they want then we should
respect their autonomy and their right
to consent yeah I think that is
we've reached and look uh I don't think
we've finished talking about it I think
this will continue to be a hot topic of
debate extraordinarily but this evening
we've learned of course that there's so
many different levels to listen people
involved uh Kate Peter thank you very
much for your views